we're only the third time Britain's
terror threat level has been raised to
its highest level police arrested three
more people this morning in connection
with Monday's bombing in Manchester
security forces are taking up positions
around the country soldiers are guarding
prominent London landmarks the Prime
Minister says another attack could be
imminent 22 people including children
were killed in this bombing officials
now say 119 people were treated at
hospitals 64 of them are still
hospitalized at this hour the new
arrests happened in the same
neighborhood where the suspected bomber
lived the country's interior minister
says the attack was likely the work of
more than one person British newspapers
are showing apparent photos of the
suicide attacker saamana Bedi was born
and raised in Manchester police are
examining his ties to Libya where his
family is from the government says he
recently traveled to Libya and possibly
Syria and he may have had ties to Isis
CBS Evening News anchor Scott Pelley is
near the scene of the attack in
Manchester Scott the good morning good
morning memorials are continuing to grow
for the victims here in Manchester the
crowd at the ariana grande concert was
primarily young of course and 22 people
including teenagers and children lost
their lives that night as they were
leaving the show police now believe they
have identified all of the victims among
the dead are John Atkinson Kelly
Brewster
Georgina Calendar Olivia campbell-martin
hebt Alison how Marcin and Angelica
Cleese Lisa Lee's and eight-year-old
Saffy Rousseau's she is the youngest
victim that we know of her principal
said that Safi was warm kind and
creative thousands of people filled
Manchester's Albert Square yesterday to
honor the bombing victims the young and
diverse crowd was so large that many
people were not able to see the vigil we
spoke with several members of the
community who told us why it was
important
them to show their support I grew up
here and this is my home and I want to
show that you know even if I'm on the
edge of the crowd you know we're here
we're showing that we're standing
against this why did you come here today
just to pay my respects basically and I
try and teach my children that things
like this is wrong viously it's a show
of sadness but also of hope yeah we are
together in Manchester ageism our bodies
King Tamar about what you believe in
despite what's happened and as bad as it
is is for us to come together and keep a
community and be there for each other
and essentially send a message through
our solidarity that they would not win
we'll have much more tonight from
Manchester on the CBS Evening News
until then back to all of you at the
broadcast Center in New York all right
Scott pally with great reporting there
from Manchester Thank You Scott and we
look forward to your coverage tonight